justin steele has looked good his last
couple of starts very adept at getting
the ball in on the hands of the
right-handed hitters overall he is three
and two with a 3.75 era
the 1-2 ground ball right side good
pitch on his hands bodhi makes the play
to schwendell out number one
bouncer over the mound might be two
bodhi steps on second throws to first
double
play real challenge for the cubs today
against the guy who really has been the
hottest pitcher in the national league
giants right-hander logan webb
first pitch of the game for logan webb
is hit on the ground that's no shock
tyra estrada playing second base throws
out ortega
wow he got half to swing and miss at a
slider that almost hit him my goodness
dominant first inning for logan webb
now buster
he swings at the first one hits a hard
ground ball past third it's a fair ball
ricochets down the left field line and
bounces off the sidewall toward the left
field corner over to field it is rivas
as buster posey heads for second and
he's in there standing with a double the
giants have two on with nobody out here
in the second
base hit center field posey around third
he'll get the go sign the throws gonna
be cut off buster scores it's one
nothing giants
did he go yes that's strike three
swinging on that slider
he threw it again he got it right on the
corner and matt duffy knew he had to
swing could not make contact
dominant start for logan webb and he
ends up walking the opposing pitcher to
start the inning and it brings up the
lead off man austin slater
line drive base hit right field there's
your classic austin slater swing
rips one to left field that's another
hit for darren ruff man he smoked that
thing base has loaded nobody out chance
for a pretty memorable moment for chris
bryant
bryant on the ground
that's gonna be
just one out so webb comes in to score
bryant fast enough to stay out of the
double play and the giants make it two
nothing
got him swinging off speed pitch out
number two
swinging a miss strike three good
fastball by justin steele
right there called strike three
that one slashed toward the hole long
throw for dubai but he got it there
perfectly that was an eight pitch inning
for logan webb
that is into center field a base hit
florence to second and holding
bouncer toward the middle that's going
to be gloved by alcantara great play to
throw him out at first
he saved the run and might have saved
the big inning this is the spot where
the gents would like to add on
he was quick
off the glove the recovery the throw too
late with the speed of austin slater
flores running on contract with two down
and it's three nothing giants
ortega drives one in the air deep center
back is slater with room on the trail
lost the ball in the sun ortega rounding
second he's going to try to go to third
and he'll make it standing up austin
slater lost that ball in the sun here's
the o2
bouncing ball slowly toward short
charging de bona run scores and the
throw to first is in time to get
schwindel owen won the count to the cubs
right fielder
here's the fly ball deep left center
going back is slater this ball's got a
chance
it's gone
in half a long home run just to the left
of dead center and the cubs are right
back in this ball game three to two so
two down and now flores and wilmer's
already had two hits against steel three
and two
fastball wilmer deep to left field way
back there
he thought maybe after that curve he
could sneak a fastball by him
wrong and wilmer is three for three 383
feet into the wrigley field bleachers
and it is five to two giants
bodhi sends one to right center
converging bryant
and slater they collide bryant's hurt
rounding second going to third is bodhi
and david vogte has a three-base hit
bryant slow to get up
he and slater collided out in right
center bryant says he's okay
nick martini pinch hitting bounces one
toward the middle this will drive in a
run
and now there are two outs but bodhi
comes in to score
on the way
swing and a miss
dip down low out of the zone one two
three for cody hoyer we go to the bottom
of the sixth inning
that's a strikeout of contreras second
time he struck contreras out two down
hit hard but right
to estrada he recovers
inning over
first and second for san
francisco longoria bounces one toward
third duffy had to wait for the bounce
gets one and they get two
five to three giants bryant the runner
at third
way outside in the dirt and it kicks
away chris bryant is gonna streak for
the plate and he will score
six to three giants so a lead off walk
for the cubs
david cracks one down the left field
line that's going to be a fair ball
bouncing against the vines racing toward
third al contra he's going to come in
and score
on a double by bode and it's six to four
tying runners at the plate robinson
torinos
he loops it down the right field line
falling that's a fair ball
bodhi's going to score torino's an rbi
single
and it's a one-run ball game
ian happ in the box meant it first and
second
half hits one in the air shadow right
center racing in bryant he can't get
there it's a base hit
everyone moves up 90. another parachute
falls in
half with a single they're loaded and
now the tying run 90 feet away
3-2 contreras takes strike three called
he thought it was inside rogers got the
call two down
3-2
is swung on and missed strike three and
it was probably ball four but he got the
chase tyler rogers how many of those
spots has he gotten through this year
two down nobody on here it is
and the change up bounced softly to
short charged by estrada and the sidearm
throw to first in time for the outer
that's a three up three down inning for
in the air to center playable for ortega
he's got it
let's see if the cubs can rally here at
wrigley's 6'5 giants well here we go
bottom nine giants trying to finish off
the cubs six to five just a one run lead
for the closer jake mcgee
wisdom hits one in the air shallow right
might be a tough play in there for a
base ship wisdom is going for two the
throw by wade to second bags not in time
top flight doubled by patrick wisdom the
time run in scoring position with one
away
the pitch
bounced to first a high hop wilmer has
it and he'll feed to mcgee for round
number two
but now the cubs are down to their last
chance
fastball on the ground and that's to
first wilmer's got it he'll run to the
bag for the put out and the giants have
swept the cubs at wrigley and the giants
magic number to clinch a spot in the
postseason is down to one